As Japan recovers from the tsunami last March,...
...the lyrics have taken on deeper meaning this year.
"The disaster showed us we need to help one another",...
...says this chorus member.
That's what this song evokes for me.
Performed and sung all through the month,...
...from concert halls to department stores,...
...no. 9 now is a welcome, if predictable, gig for Japanese musicians and conductors.
I have done this more than 150 times.
Some hardcore fans even try to sing it in German.
"I don't know all the words", says this 9-year-old,...
..."I just fake it."
For sheer scale, nothing beats the 10,000 man no. 9 chorus of Osaka.
Talented and tone-deaf alike,...
...all vie for the chance to stand on stage.
Healing note for a shattered nation.
Lucy Craft, CBS News, Osaka.